hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar the molecular analysis
on circulating tumor cells to determine
prognostic and predictive factors in
cancer research i'm judy oracle efforts
and i'll be moderating the session
today's educational web seminars
presented by lab routes leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it brought to you by cryogens
whether your passion for answers take
you to a laboratory bench or a hospital
bedside the pursuit often begins with a
blood or tissue sample the deepest
mysteries of disease and other
biological processes are encoded in the
building blocks of life DNA working with
these molecules is quite a journey and
we acquired and understand these
challenges cryogen offers you innovative
solutions that cover every single step
along this journey not just technology
with bridges from samples to incite
samples to incite means hydrogen offers
you the industry's most reliable sample
technologies because samples matter to
your success or top quality assays and
panels enable you to accurately analyze
and identify diseases and genetic
variation or bioinformatics software and
curated knowledge bases transform your
raw data into relevant actionable
findings and our automation solutions
provide you seamless and cost-effective
workflows sample to incite the insights
you gain may lead to one small step or
giant leap forward for science and
health care partnering with kyochon your
work can make a difference now let's get
started you can post questions to the
speaker during the presentation while
they're fresh in your mind to do so
simply type them in the Q&A box which
will open when you click the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problems by clicking on the
green Q&A button at low
lest by now presented a speaker screen
ouch PhD the director of liquid biopsy
and site manager at kyochon in hanover
germany dr. siegfried out study biology
at the Albert Einstein University in
room and holds a PhD in plant physiology
and molecular biology he served as
director of R&D at edna gene since 2006
to build the admin team circulating
tumor cells business in 2015 dr. Alex
was appointed as director of liquid
biopsy and site manager at kyochon
Hanover gmbh now he is responsible for
these circulating tumor cell business at
kyochon dr. out will now begin his
presentation thank you very much for
this long and kind introduction and
thank you all so very much to the
auditory that dialed in as far as I know
worldwide so I say hello good afternoon
good evening and good morning to the
auditory so talking about liquid biopsy
there's a very interesting and and a
very challenging field in the moment and
and there is many approaches actually
how one could address that and we really
have to have to focus today to the
circulating tumor cells only because I
could talk for another three hours of
about all the rest so forgive me that
it's only about CTCs today but i hope i
can kind of convince you that it's not
that the distances ctc content that we
have here what we can learn from the
circulating tumor cells contributes so
much to the liquid biopsy peer that
finally we would not like to live
without it so my title is here
harnessing the high value of circulating
tumor cells in liquid biopsy and before
I can really start I would like to bring
up this a little disclaimer here telling
you a lot of things but mainly that we
are talking about research today we are
not
about the clinical routine and the
clinical Diagnostics is only about
research and the use of circulating
tumor cells as a part of the liquid
biopsy challenge in such endeavor so let
me see before we can people died in
today I would like to introduce you to
the test system that we developed and
used in that context in our research
work and this is the end the test
principle which is actually an easy
principle on one hand but a tricky one
on the other hand so what do we do you
may have heard if you are if you are in
that field already you may have heard
about immunomagnetic cell enrichment
which is quite commonly discussed in the
field of ctcs over years and also the
use of transcriptome profiling to
characterize the CTC so what is
different with the advertised principle
here and this is the so-called body
called co CP principle it means
combination of combinations principle
and it starts first with an immuno
magnetic selection of oil enrichment of
the cells that is not as common as you
may think so we do not use a single
antibody directed against a single tumor
antigen to enrich the cells from the
blood because we learn very early even
in 2004 already that once the CTC appear
in the plant in other words once the
tumor disseminates CT sees into the
bloodstream there is a dramatic change
in phenotype and profile ourselves to
make that happen using only a specific
antibody that might be aware that might
be expressed on the cells in the tumor
tissue can easily easily be lost during
this transformation process and if you
use such a kind of an epitope for
selection you
I'd not find yourself anymore and might
get false negative the part here how how
we dealt with that issue was that we use
a mixture of different feed populations
containing different antibodies
direction again various epitopes on the
tumor cells all in order to kind of
being prepared that if one or two of
them is lost there is still an epitope
available that can be used for the input
will be used for the enrichment doing so
you are quite successful and have very
high sensitivity in the CTC capturing
which is due to detect that is then
followed by the start of the a Dem RNA
isolation and a reverse transcription to
get cdna important to understand here
that we are not visualizing the cells we
immediately lies the cells because we
say the cell as such is does not contain
d or is not the important information
the important information that we want
to explore is what is in themselves what
information can we get out of debt and
this is much more than only knowing that
their idea and the second combination of
the combination of combinations
principle is then multiplex pcr approach
again following the same idea that the
expression profiles in circulating tumor
cells might be highly variable and
therefore you need to address several
tumor markers on the apparent a basis to
make sure that you may not miss the
selves or may not get negative findings
because only because of what what is
follow or the other of the mattress is
not over expressed in these cells the
rule is here for the detection of ctcs a
one of the markets we we we have there
in the multiplex PCR reaction is getting
positive this is counted as a proof for
the presence of ctcs so this is about
the COC principle the cotp principle and
how it works
how does that look like in practice so
the air that has is a benchtop si there
is not much automation on if they
actually today there is no automation is
it's a manual test it's a very
straightforward procedure you start with
5 milliliters of blood you incubate the
blood with the beads and for 30 minutes
at room temperature this is followed by
several washing steps actually so and
after all these washing steps are done
you have to enrich tumor cells there to
give you an idea about how much the
enrichment will or how we can kind of
quantified enrichment quality is that in
the normal amethyst essays we have been
about 1,000 leukocytes still
contaminating the CDC's but this is
already good enough to go into the RT
and multiplex PCR reaction with a very
high specificity depending on the Marcus
you are analyzing here there are already
several tests available commercially
available in the market that is a test
for breast cancer for prostate cancer
the Edit F colorectal cancer the end has
ovarian cancer and three more essays
that are mostly used and in the research
field today this is the end test ovarian
cancer to that deals with emt like cells
in the ovarian CTC field and the admin
has EMT one and EMT to stem cell that is
dedicated to not only address epithelial
light cells in the blood but also cells
under EMT epithelial-mesenchymal
transition or cells that have a tumor
stem cell-like phenotype in order to
also identifies ourselves and look what
kind of metabolism is behind such cells
okay enough about the test so I hope I
could briefly describe you what kind of
approach we used here for what I have to
tell you enough because what are we
really asking from CTCs did we
place the right questions and dips etc's
tell us all they could so far this is
what it's about and if we are now
starting with the broadness prognostic
information that we can obtain if we
look at CTCs this is only one side of
the coin actually so it's an important
site of the coin but finally not enough
and not leading to the final decision
making something that a doctor may need
to change his treatment to treat the
patient better nevertheless using the
technology I described to you there are
several papers out there that we really
can't show this is confirmed there is
prognostic information in the CTC
content DCTC presence if circulating
tumor cells are there in the circulation
either after surgery or during a therapy
and the therapy is not removing the
cells from the blood stream then this is
a bad prognostic tacker published I gave
you hear a few publications there are
much more but I think this is kind of
initial applications we made in that
context for several tumor entities this
is true for breast cancer colon cancer
for prostate cancer too we found it in
ovarian cancer and also applying the emt
one and stem cell-like test we found
that also for the two most M&S live
cells and the emt serves in human breast
cancer what does that mean I show you
here a few results so this study was
made by sub inactive Sabina Kazuma power
from the University of Athens in 2014
published at d-san Antonio Breast Cancer
Symposium in that year that means that
circulating tumor cells in primary
breast cancer for instance if they are
there after surgery this patient
population shows a verse disease-free
survival actually compared to the
patients where the CDC's we are not
detectable after sir
in principle that's a good idea because
it could help us to divide the the
patient cohort into subgroups one is
that is under much higher risk and one
that has rather no risk to form
metastasis really there is only one
problem with prognostic information and
that is the question that always comes
from the apologists to me but do I have
something what I can do to help the
cohort that is under risk and this is a
very very important question because it
cannot be really answered until now
except if you see what we found in in
terms of predictive information because
that is really where we have to come to
the prognostic information is nice but
we have to tell the doctors order or
give the doctors the information what to
do now with their patients one per se in
breast cancer okay also observe them
better give them longer treatment of
whatever you give adjuvant even the
second edge of an terapeak could be
discussed in that context but still the
question remains will then really help
and this is the question that we have to
Archer nevertheless you can see here
again the same story in breast cancer in
the metastatic situation even even more
clear if CTCs are there under therapy
and they stay there and to therapy is
not able to remove the seed CTCs from
the blood the patients have a much
shorter overall survival than the
patients where this is not the case
important in this study done by tables
at all in 2009 important here is that
all these patients had a very long
terapi history we do not we are not in
third line we are even behind third line
here and even though these patients if
the CT sees get removed by the therapy
from the blood the patients have a much
much longer survival than the patient's
where this is not happening bye-bye as a
consequence of the therapy
in ovarian cancer as you can imagine
it's even more clear ovarian cancer
before and or after surgery the CTCs
have a very even before surgery the
CDC's have a very clear prognostic
information if CTCs detected by the Aten
test ovarian cancer are already there
before surgery these patients show a
much shorter overall survival compared
to patient patience that receipt ec-
before therapy and this is even more
clear for the disease free survival
after roughly 30 months all the patients
that had CDC's before therapy relapsed
whereas at least forty percent of the
patients had no relapse until 60 months
also very clear information that we get
from the sea disease as such these
patients are much much higher risk for
Matt metallization in ovarian cancer but
again the question can we do something
against that do we have a more
information of the CDC's can we get out
more information of the city sees we
reanalyzed here to help these patients
really not only to tell them okay you
are risk route now your chance to
develop mastered metastasis earlier is
probably higher but we have no
therapeutic option to treat them better
to give them a better chance and to help
them better the same you can see also in
prostate cancer did hear a study with
total vapor at all in 2012 we can
clearly see that CTC even give us an
idea about therapy response or not you
can in-depth study the CTC negative
group the city and the group under
remission never showed CT sees before
therapy they did not show CT seized
during therapy all few CT seized during
therapy and never see disease after
therapy the other the other situation we
see on in contrast in the in the
progressive group here we do always find
CTCs either before therapy or after but
they will never see tc- as such so it's
a good discriminator it's a good
discriminator for therapy responsiveness
but we have still not an idea about what
to do now as a consequence of these
findings and therefore I bring you out
to the most important chapter of this
top city sees do they have the potential
to give us predictive information and
three of the papers I already mentioned
for the prognostic value may be chosen
here in colorectal cancer in prostate
and ovarian cancer we really could find
such kind of predictive information and
there is even one more in breast cancer
which I will bring you as a highlight in
the end of the presentation let's look
to colorectal cancer we found indeed the
circulating tumor cells are again
prognostic but also in a group that has
wild-type k russ and is therefore
treated with the taksim up in
panitumumab musella at all in 2015 in
milano they observed that finding in
their trial than CT sees or that there
is a certain group of therapy not
generic therapy non-responders to anti
kara's therapy and they were asking
themselves by is dead and they used NCT
ceased to as a potential explain for
what could happen here and indeed what
you can see even progression
progression-free survival but also
overall survival is clearly correlated
to circulating tumor cells in colorectal
cancer patients the question comes not
up why is that solve why are these
patients not responding to a terror
even get a wild type r us rob patients
huh it's not flipping forward let me see
what I can do so and you can even even
drive it further you can even make it
more stringent and analyze that in
favorable and unfavorable but
nevertheless it's always always the same
message here circulating tumor cells are
the reason for K or seem to be I must be
scientific here seem to be the reason
for Anna to mobile failure in chaos
wild-type patients and there might be a
certain explanation for that and this is
presented here in another trial we did
with the group at at policlinico enroll
around raimondi at all in 2013 we
analyzed the CTCs and compared them to
tissue while time at issue mutants and
we add it to the normal colorectal SI
another another molecule is a testing
for k russ over expression and this is
the interesting result we found here in
the tissue mutated patients none of them
even if it's a small cohort here but
highly significant in the tissue mutated
cohort none of them showed CTCs with k
russ overexpression pad in the tissue
wild-type patients the CTC is that we
found their we're in fifty percent of
the cases showed shorter k runs over
expression signature which could be
fairly explained that we might be able
to identify anti Kira's planning to move
up treated patients that will not
respond to the treatment not because of
they have a k russ mutation but because
of they have another amplification of
the chaos that leads to the same effect
and this is decay Russ overexpression
another picture to the same story and
they already kind of
leading into the right direction here we
can predict it will look either option I
don't want to jump into something unless
he's hesitant with a mechanic an ele I
don't think you'll have problems
justifying it at the insurance level
because of the that I can hear plea is
not right this level of bleeding so
that's not a problem you tell me Keith
Urban you can like a bodega to any
capacity we happen there is somebody in
the line okay yeah I'm here yeah how
that is why you that's what I'm lots of
local blanket so GI tachometer know we
should know any make out so that is
killer dr. Bullock enemy everything I
nes at a TK v nicola sorry I cannot
understand what we said really here I
must say master Ganga that is the
problem that i can write that again okay
go ahead I will talk to him sorry about
that okay okay so so what I'm trying to
explain you is the following thing that
that there is more to see but the
important message is the right way where
we should focus probably we should focus
to a therapy a prediction so what we can
see here really in a certain therapeutic
regimen and predict that this
therapeutic regimen is probably
effective or not this is already the
kind of prediction I would say this is
more at least then prognosis but i will
show you more than it was even more in
the direction of prediction and this is
here all my next slide you have seen the
prognostic effect of ctcs in ovarian
cancer but more than that we try to find
predictive information in these cancer
cells and therefore we were looking for
jeans that could predict kind of than
something against the normal therapeutic
regimens you give in ovarian cancer and
one of them is first line flat
therapy that is a very common therapy
form that usually ovarian cancer
patients get at the first instance and
we analyze a special gene in top of the
genes that are not normally in the
ovarian cancer test and this is the gene
ercc1 and we tested the overexpression
of ercc1 which is a DNA it belongs to
the DNA repair genes family we choosing
that because of platinum is working as a
DNA damaging therapy in in tumor cells
and therefore the overexpression of
repair gene could fairly lead to
platinum resistance and indeed this was
the case ctc and you see that in the
last line of this table here CTC is
positive for ercc1 we are not only
highly and independently prognostic even
to be demonstrated in the cox regression
for disease free survival and when I say
independent this I mean independent of
the normal staging peckers actually but
we found also to them to be an
independent factor for platinum
resistance in other words if we see
patients before surgery I I should say
that to that before surgery we analyze
the patience for ercc1 positive CDC's if
we find them it is most likely that
these patients will not respond after
surgery to the adjuvant platinum
first-line therapy this is already
coming very close to predictive
information the only what we would like
to provide now is an alternative but
this could be already second line or a
kind of kind of paclitaxel based
combination therapy or or even kind of
personalized therapy with the upcoming
olaparib which is quite under discussion
in the moment and this story metal some
of you may already have heard this is
one of one of the latest proof that we
could could deliver in terms of
predicting therapy failure relief before
the onset of the therapy the group
around the Johns Hopkins research guys
that control Iraqis and yoona do
analyzed using the an intense prostate
cancer an additional gene for its
expression profile and this is the
antigen receptor variant 7 and what they
found was super interesting they found
if the prostate cancer patients I should
say here castrate resistant metastatic
prostate cancer if they were positive
positive CTCs for a RV 7 so if a RV 7
was overexpressed in CDC's found there
these patients absolutely did not
respond anymore to appear at a boner or
enzalutamide this was a super clear
message here ARV 7 as a self
constitutively activated variant of
androgen receptor is making the
enzalutamide and the a beer at around
therapy useless this could save a lot of
money this could save a lot of time to
these patients if one would switch to an
alternative form and the same group in
the year after the data are not shown
here but the same group in the year
after could really demonstrate also that
instead of giving them enzalutamide or a
beer at opponent these patients were
very nicely responding to park ataxia
which would be in this case a super good
alternative to a treatment of which we
know based on the CTC information that
this therapeutic regimens will not work
at all and now as promised I come to the
the latest the last chapter in in
predictive information and this
about breast cancer and it's about CT
sees that we find there and analyzed for
her2 overexpression and what this may
tell us the idea to that came from us a
piece of research that we did long ago
it was in 2006 I think also when Vienna
when we compared in primary in primary
breast cancer the her2 status order to
mRNA status in CT CS and compared that
to the her2 status in primary tissue and
the interesting finding was here that
only in fifty percent of the cases we
had concordance and in another fifty
percent of the cases we had discordant
between tissue and the CDC's twenty-one
percent of the see her true positive
CTCs were negative and tissue for her
two and thirty percent of the tissue
positive CDC's were negative for her2
expression in DC disease so seeing that
we thought wow that's an interesting
story and but this Ted real is that real
has been the consequence and indeed it
has a consequence we had a chance in
2013 to compare metastatic tissue with
the CDC's we found there directly and
here we found another story giver to
expression on the cities in the
metastatic situation was clearly
correlated to the phenotype of the
metastatic tissue is what it was not
easy to get because you know reto
metastatic tissue is difficult to get
and difficult to obtain but in these
cases where we could make that happen we
found indeed there is a good correlation
to the metastatic tissues if you only
analyze the CDC's this is something
where I would say a very good example
what really is liquid biopsy means
because you have an easy access to that
it's minimal invasive but you get
information about the metastatic fino
I the metastatic tissue phenotype and
again probably an indication how to
treat this patients then because if this
is real this metastasis and this
metastatic tissue should based on these
results respond to an anti her to
targeted therapy interestingly by the
way we did not find that really in when
we when we stay in the city cease using
the cell search approach for her to
positivity we found no correlation we
were asking ourselves why can't that
happen and and finally we found out a
potential reason for that because if we
were looking to the CTC order to the
patient we found here and the CDC's
analyzed using the editors without
there's fifty percent of DC TCS lost at
hem but instead of over expressed her to
this might be an explanation why the
added test using a multi antibody
capturing approach still captures these
cells and their forget gets that
information whereas the cell search
approach only dealing with AB cam was
probably missing the cells of interest
and therefore there is no correlation
here to the metastatic tissue could be
one explanation what should people look
into that to confirm it based on these
results we thought we go now one step
further we want to have more information
about the metabolism that is ongoing
here and therefore we apply to the cdna
we got from such patient samples a whole
panel of of genes of interest that we
wanted to see during several changes of
therapy in follow-up the genes we were
looking at you see here on the right
hand side this is her 3 / 2 aah one fkm
c-met aurora kinase pi3k ercc1 which we
know from the ovarian because of
platinum resistance a few controls like
cd45 to somehow get an idea of how many
leukocytes interfere here gap th as a
marker and also the mg related akt2
another tyrosine kinase egfr the design
of the study was like follows we
enrolled the patients under progression
and at the time point t 0 from there on
they got a standard therapy which we did
not interfere with what the doctor said
but we we after eight to 12 weeks or so
we kind of stage the patients in non
rest in a non responder group and the
responder group again we took a sample
and analyzed for CT sees and for that
panel and then we in the non responder
group they switched to therapy to an
alternative in the responder group they
stayed with the same therapy as before
after another 12 weeks we again group
them and stage them in overall
non-responder group in a late responder
group in a late nonresponder group and
into an overall responder field we got
many results out there and the paper
about that is is already under its
accepted for publication should be out
in probably a month or two from now with
all the detailed results to not steal
too much of your time I give you only
hear a kind of a summary of the most
important findings I think here and this
is comparing now the responder the
overall responder group as an example
with the non responder group over all
the time points t0 t1 and t2 44
dedicated genes the first is at camp
where we can clearly see that in there
you see that in red then in the overall
nonresponder group we start at time
point t 0 with an with an frequency of
fifty percent means fifty percent of the
CTC positive patients there were
positive for FM two and over the course
of the therapies in the non responder
group this was increasing all
time until nearly 80-percent also where
rather than in the overall responder
group the level was was decreasing over
the cause of the therapy from 40 to
roughly thirty percent the same for our
Laura kinase which we've chosen also as
a kind of marker for the therapy
responded therapy resistance and here we
also see that in the non responder group
or raw kinase seems to be very much
coronated with that starting with a
frequency of thirty percent in the
beginning at t0 and increasing to up to
over sixty percent at the time point t 2
whereas in the overall responder group
the lavender frequency of hurricanes
positive CTC stay the same or even was
decreasing a little bit but now to the
most important ones look at her too and
again think about what we said about her
to the last two slides we see at time
point t 0 a positivity rate a frequency
for her to around ten percent for both
groups but in the non responder groups
group the frequency of her to
overexpressing CTCs was raising to forty
percent and did not decline again did
not decrease again at time point t to
the important thing to to say here is
what we are talking about here is really
newly acquired her2-positive these
patients did not have her to positive
CDC's before they did in most of the
cases not even have a very positive
tissue before this is 42 that comes as a
reason of therapy resistance and I can
see that so whereas in the group of the
overall responders you do not see that
the segment also starts with probably
ten percent frequency in the beginning
at time point t 0 but nearly gets to 0
at time point t 2 and in combination to
divert
to the combination to the her to another
very interesting g indy her three which
is an actually in active transcription
factor are not inactive tyrosine kinase
but that is able to activate her to and
egfr by diamond formation and also for
is her three we see the same phenomenon
starting in the non responder group and
in the responder group at ten percent
frequency at time point t 0 and then
increasing dramatically to nearly fifty
percent so every second of these
patients was then positive for her too
in addition whereas it stayed roughly at
the ten percent level in D in the
overall responder group taking this
together with the findings that we had
before I should go back and show you
clearly what I mean with the findings
that such CT seas are correlated to the
corresponding metastatic tissue in terms
of there were two profile for me the
study clearly showed really that we
could we have a group of patients here
that probably could be a very good
candidate for entire to or entire three
directed therapy as a predictive
consequence of such findings so we are
very close in to the the end of the
session today only two slides a summary
the molecular detection of circulating
tumor cells during the athletics has
been proven and published and
peer-reviewed to be a very highly
sensitive and the super specific method
devised a specific I'm talking about a
specificity of ninety-five percent or
better to identify CTCs and to analyze
them for molecular content of the CDC's
in other words we have opened the box
and look into it and we can get
prognostic and predictive information
out of that using the other tests we so
far could show
that they are able to monitor therapy
efficacy and to determine that right
after the beginning of the treatment
about in cycle 21 also means very early
in the treatment giving probably the
chance then to make changes of the
treatment if there is an indication to
do so but even more did the last two
points are the most important I think in
that context what I wanted to to tell
you now today and that is that the
molecular characterization of ctcs has
for me now proven that it shows emt and
tumor cell site stem cell related
phenotypes and they are linked to
resistance to conventional therapy
asking for alternatives here and the
Edna test is an open platform and this
is an important information for you
researchers in the in the auditory it's
an open platform that enables the
investigation of characteristics or
profiles and CTCs based on your research
that that you I actually do you are not
limited to the 2d content that we offer
with our kids here is wide open and you
can analyze whatever profile you may
make want to analyze to probably even
find such interesting predictive
information at least a hint for flash
predictive information in your own or
research having dead set I came to the
come to the end I hope I could give you
a little idea about the interesting
field CT sees in the whole context of
liquid biopsy which is also circulated
free DNA exosomes and whatever we can
imagine to have their everything is of
importance everything in that liquid
biopsy field can bring good information
to help the patients further and to have
the doctors to treat the patients
further and to make them a longer life
and this is what it's all about thank
you very much for your attention thank
you dr. Oxford presentation a quick
reminder for our audience on how is the
questions simply type them in the Q&A
box found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window dr. actual answer as
many questions as time permits and the
first question is in regards to the
acquisition and management of CT seeds
how can we better determine whether the
acquisition of CTC influences their
behavior or molecular profile at the
time of the assay yeah that's that's a
question I hear rather often and it has
to do with sample preparation so what
needs to be done to guarantee a certain
stability of the cdc's from blood roll
to lab bench you need to stabilize the
cdc's in a way and this is not easy to
do really you need to do it in a way
that it sells maintain viable you should
not change their expression profile and
until they arrive to the lab bench we we
found two solutions for it one solution
is the ethical neck tube that we that we
distribute in Europe which is ced
approved and can be sold in Europe but
not in the United States for the United
States we found another strategy that
uses BD vacutainer the ACD a peeve are
containers compared with a kind of an in
lab stabilization that has to be done
before you incubate with the beach and
this at least guarantees the stability
of what we are looking here and we've
proven that in spiking experiments but
also in patient samples did get
guarantees a stability of about 36 hours
not not more unfortunately but 36 hours
already is I think time enough to get a
blood samples from the paint to the
bench side what role does EMT play in
ctc and how does it affect the analysis
ctc there really
PMT is is a big role I didn't mention
too much in this in this presentation
about that but we have other webinars
upcoming by the gold or deeper into into
the emt field CT ceased to be able to
escape the tissue must be transformed in
a way see they must get from an
epithelial cell that is not able to
migrate to something that can migrate
and therefore people say this is a
mesenchymal itself like something and
the process that leads to death
phenomenon is the so-called EMT process
so there is a phenotype change that
allows the cells at least to escape from
the tissue and to get into the blood
vessel by overexpressing or down
regulating certain genes that are
necessary to to get out of the tissue
really like down-regulation of e
catering for example and the
upregulation of n-cadherin and to even
break through the blood vessel and get
into the circulation examples for death
many-fold we found it for example in the
breast cancer field genes involved here
are a katie to the pi3k pathway p10 mtor
but also a certain certain other pathway
shortcuts over egfr but leading always
in into this akt area there is other
indications in colorectal cancer that
it's k rusted plays a role here and we
had findings in lung cancer dead sea met
is the driver of EMT in cement ok now
that Sarah fine the blood and how do
these cells survive in the plot really
so because usually body defense is very
good and you should kill themselves like
that and here comes over the EMT also
the CTC tumor stem stem less phenotype
into the play that makes it possible
that CTC is mimic themselves to be stem
cell-like they don't regulate MHC class
protein
they articulate PDL one or kind of anti
t cell proteins on the on the surface to
be invisible for the immune system
Sophie MTN CTCs is a very common very
necessary and very often observable
process what is the best method to use
enriched epc for mutation analysis oh
that's that's a good question so for
mutation analysis CTCs are usually and
this is my personal opinion a tricky
tricky sample to use and I would say
it's not a matter of the enrichment
process really it's a matter of the
either/or no content of DNA that we have
here if you think about that we usually
have frequencies of 10 CTCs in a 5 ml
blood draw in here I would say we should
probably more focus on circulating 3d
and a to address this mutation issue at
least on the time at the time being we
are working on mutation analysis in CT
sees indeed but it's it's a tricky thing
and needs a lot of optimization and good
ideas in the future give me another two
years then I tell you more about that
will you optimize the adult system in
such a way that it would be possible to
enrich CTC so that they can be cultured
yes I know even using the add a test
that several groups around in a
university in Prague used to CT sees
enriched by by the labeling method by
positive selection using beads and they
were able to get bring T cells in
culture I could probably think about
also label free labor free methods could
have an advantage over the labeling the
beat
ctc isolation processes I have no clear
opinion about it it's not very often
done I didn't didn't see too many papers
or research about that but what is there
another issue that one should take into
consideration under the monster very
limited research I have seen so far in
that context there seems to be also one
message and this is that it's not even
if you get them viable and label free
it's not easy to take the city sees in
into to get them to grow because of you
they are these emt light phenotype there
might be even a growth inhibition in
such a situation and therefore it's not
easy to to get them really in culture in
that situation and if they don't grow
the question is are they still the same
than they were before well thank you
said i would like to once again strength
dr. out for his presentation do you have
any final comments no actually not i'm
happy i am one common property i hope i
could kind of triggered the interest in
the auditory to try to get more
information about CTCs try to do
research in the receipt ec fields I from
my perspective I can say it's super
interesting there is so much information
we do not have yet and again one thing
to remind you what we are doing that for
is for the patient survival and for
making them a longer and better life
thank you I'd also like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions and we would
like to thank our sponsor cryogen for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand
through November 12 2016 lab roots will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues from we
have missed today's live event until
next time good bye bye